hey what's up guys my name is a channel
opened episode 69 of game programming so
yesterday we took a look at um well a
few things first of all fixing up this
damn code saleable making it draggable
and we've pretty much got everything
pretty much sorted out now so the
hardest part of this thing honestly was
just pretty much getting the angle that
we want to shoot at and we've done that
so that's awesome
everything else is pretty damn amazing
so let's go on if I can projectile stuff
because that is fun so what do we want
to do right if we shoot which is right
over here
what do we actually want to do first of
all we've now got the UM direction in
degrees and we might change that in a
minute we'll see but let's remove that
system thing what should we do now let's
see okay other direction what we need
okay cool there's a few things I kind of
don't want to do um okay let's just make
a projectile class I should do it
so we'll probably do it in entity should
it be an entity let's just add a new
class here we'll put it probably into
home doctor no dot brain I'm just
thinking and to your book it will make
it an entity I guess um I almost don't
want today
I don't think um I guess we'll make it
extend entity just for now I don't know
if it should they're like I mean I don't
probably not will say projectile will
say what entity actually has an emic
inside so entity has okay it's go remove
that's good is removed now we pretty
much do want it to be an entity because
I'm just looking through this and I'm
like yeah pretty much all that all this
is what a projectile should be so I
guess what make an entity okay and this
is just going to be the UM superclass
for all these things so in other words
in the projectile package here will
happen else will have different
projectiles so like I'll make one called
uh okay this is where you guys really
have to decide our guy kind of looks
like a wizard so I'm just gonna make it
a class full wizard projectile okay and
you
being the projectile package the
pre-health folder and that will
obviously extend projectile alright so
in other words projectile is probably
going to be an abstract class at this
point that will contain everything we
need to make projectile basically so
first thing we need is actually is a
constructor
okay so projectile what do we need right
let's just think about it this way what
do we need for projectile there are so
many things we can we actually need
right but some of these things could be
actually set by this so um instead of
actually starting with the constructor
let's start with other things that we
might need so protected we probably need
well we should have a final protected
integer for the X origin and the Y
origin so this is where the this is
actually where the thing spawns at okay
we definitely need that and again it
will be final um we also need why did I
do it that way that is bizarre so this
way it looks much nicer this way okay
productive final int X hydrogen we
probably also need the angle well we
definitely need the angle protect a
double angle and you probably need a
sprite will definitely a sprite and
let's just call it quits for now I think
I guess we should probably should we do
it that way I will have to do that way
anyway so I guess well also I'm doing
this on the fly so I apologize for my
non professionalism I guess I don't know
protected um ah double an X NN y so this
is just going to be the vector
translation says it's going to be like
the new ax and you Y this will change
each each step each tick each update or
if you can call it okay so here we have
to do a few things first of all we
clearly need to fill out these final
fields that's why it's giving us this
because why our genetics Hajin
not have been initializing they have to
be so we definitely definitely need X&Y
we also need the direction definitely
and there's a million other things that
we could add such as you know damage
speed range rate of fire right so many
different like modifiers we can but I
think they'll be pretty little specific
specific so I'll basically talk about
that meezerman in a minute but um we
definitely would need um let's just make
them right now so let's see our speed is
one I just make it as a double
so speed rate of fire and what else
should we add to this awesome thing what
was the other thing I said um role range
is definitely one I don't think I said
that last I do that Oh damage so we've
got all these different things right but
what I'm thinking right now is that you
know why add why add all all these
things into the constructor like that's
useless because I think that we'll just
add them to all the subclasses so for
example wizard projectile you know that
might have a static damage thing all
right I'm thinking about now that might
not be the case because player
modifications might be able to extend
ranges and everything um maybe not I'm
not sure anyway let's just leave it at
that for now we can change it later
it'll be really easy to change so don't
worry okay awesome so let's just set
these things so X origin needs to equal
x and y origin needs 2 for Y and then I
can get rid of those problems okay
that's why what else do we have
so with the direction angle equals
direction okay that should be it
all right so over here we just use super
as we did and then we can set a few
other things so like we can set the
range right now to be about out of our
300 maybe we'll see maybe maybe bit less
what I'm going to implement right
straight away though so you guys can see
why we actually need a range
maybe damage like 20 haveno right a fire
might like 15 and again we won't
implement all these now I'm just adding
random values here
okay angle um let's see um when we use
math to cosign of stuff do we need the
angle and degrees or in radians um we
should need in radians but I think we
needed in degrees now we need an in
radians okay cool so in that case we
don't actually have to do anything doing
we're just set okay we just set this to
angle okay we went to another okay
awesome
Oh actually it's due up because I'm
gonna introduce you guys to some vector
maths so I hope you guys are I hope you
guys at least know what vectors are like
but you know I didn't tell myself that I
would assume pretty much no knowledge
from you guys um and that's fine like I
don't mind explaining this stuff it's
fun I guess um okay so let's go never
got that graphics have a dad anyway um
okay so how do vectors work that's what
we're gonna cover today vectors okay so
I vectors okay sorry vectors why do we
need them and how do we use them first
of all vectors basically tell us um well
vectors are another way of storing
Corden's pretty much but instead of you
know storing coordinates in an x and y
fashion you know we can store
coordinates in a polarized fashion which
basically means that each coordinate has
an angle and a length alright and that's
just meant to be a little one about a
comma there okay so we know the angle of
something and we know how long it's
supposed to be right thus we have a
vector because we know that we know what
that angle is alright and we know the
length or the magnitude of that vector
okay so that's basically our vectors
work so instead of x and y based or
angle in length which is awesome because
what we then need to do right is pretend
this is a little player here we want to
fire a projectile in let's just say this
direction okay now what has to happen
that what we actually have to do
right to be able to fire their
projectile in that angle right in
theater angle here what we need to do is
we need to animate it you know we can't
animate that that we can't we cannot
animate diagonally can we what we can do
though is animate on the x axis and the
y axis so what we what we do actually do
is we say okay move it this much towards
the X you know move it this much on the
x axis and this model of the y axis and
so what we actually get is something
that looks like this okay but it's
really precise as pixelpro is basically
pixel precision so it looks smooth but
that's basically how we do this so what
we need to use vectors for is to figure
out how much we should move on the x
axis every tick or every update and how
much we should move on the y axis every
tick or every update okay so that's why
we can use two things we can use cause
to work out X and we can use sine so
cosine and sine and we can assign to
work out and there should be Sam ah why
okay we can use those two mathematical
functions to actually give us those
values so it really is that simple so
let's just implement that right now so
new X right that's what we're actually
traveling should basically equal math
dot cosine of the angle right and why
should a called mouth don't post math
dot sine of the angle right is that
correct
and by a mean angle yeah
is that correct well kind of okay the
thing is this will move it very slowly
okay because this is going to give us a
number there's basically going to be
between like what 0 and 1 or something
like that maybe 0 2 it's going to be
really really small you know what we
want to do is just say okay move that
much but you know let's multiply it by a
multiplier but I like to fall for
example again the multiplier we will
actually use here it's probably the
speed of the projectile so let's set a
speed here as well - like twine let's
just set it to like 4 for now and then
we'll just multiply it speed times that
yeah and so now it'll move you know that
much on the X but it'll just be
amplified by the speed so that we
actually get something that moves at a
decent rate we can actually
well how fast it moves again which is
yeah really awesome make sure these are
the same though right so don't do like
speed times too you know here and then
just like this like that because that
will obviously not going the answer do
you want us to go on because X will be
moving faster than Y okay that is ah
basically how we do that again now we do
have to do a few things in the update
method now um you know that we kind of
extend that so if we go public void up
to it then you can see that we actually
override and they want an entity we're
just right here okay so we're I want
entity oh close I was it projectiles
over that back up okay so an update when
you do a lot of things first of all what
we actually need to do is we kind of
need a work out well okay let's move the
think first of all we'll just probably
pop this here there and I'll make it
protected okay awesome and that over
eyes that one obviously
so in move will do a few things first of
all we need to basically well think of
it as the move thing in mob right well
when we move the mob what we do well
basically we just check for collision
and then move it on separate access okay
well actually we check for we separate
the axes first and then we move it in
separate axis same thing here right but
we won't we weren't worried about
collision for now so X right and
obviously our entity here has an
exposition not this entity my entity has
next my position so we'll again we'll
just put mag X plus equal guess what
guess what we're going to make it
possible
any guesses n X okay and y plus equals
NY and guys that is as simple as it is
okay that is literally as simple as it
is that is how we make a projectile I
know Matt across the screen in a
particular direction because we've
already made this vector really easily
here
umm and then now what we have to do is
just animate it by those two modifiers
and we did which is awesome so that's
pretty sick that's yeah actually took
less time than the photo would so yeah
that's basically what it's going to do
now let's talk about actually adding
them I don't know how much time we have
left probably I'm that much time left
but I'm just gonna probably finish
something now today just just so you
guys can have fun with it I guess um mmm
okay so let's go back to our projectile
where are we let's go back to our player
this is what we actually shoot so when
we shoot this happens once get rid of
that let's just cover that up enough
because we want the angle not in um
degrees what we need to do here is
actually well add a project add
projectile right and then we want to
render it so every time the shoot method
runs we've shot something so we need
make a new projectile so for this case
I'll probably just make it a new wizard
projectile that's one that we just made
with X Y Direction that's correct
okay and it once Direction is an integer
should we keep it that way
probably not yeah let's just cast xx
right away it's fine we don't really
need to be that precise we might change
that later we'll see okay so now we've
got all that stuff figured out we need
to make an ArrayList it holds
projectiles now I kind of don't want to
make it here though um I want to make it
in my level so we'll just probably say
that ah
there's so many reasons not to make it
in level though now let's make it in mop
okay and I'll tell you why in a minute
so protected a list projectile so
projectiles
equals new ArrayList critter files
product I'll okay so I so the reason I
made this in mob and on level even
though I was very tempted to actually
put it into level was because because
this way we can actually trace back who
owns which projectile really easily we
can just ask to display the instance of
that mob and then we can just basically
know who the projectile so allow is
going to be really important in the
future because as in realm of the mad
God if we kill something we want to get
the XP so we need to know what project
I'll actually killed it and we can trace
that back and be like okay I belong to
this mob so give him you know hundred XP
or whatever so that's gonna be a lot of
fun when we get to that stage I promise
you we still do need to add it to the
level thing though it is an entity um so
what we need to do is let's just
purchase the projectiles dot ad PA might
actually change that to shots instead of
projectiles but we'll think about that
no matter unless level dot ad do we not
have that figured out
come on right really we have an odd
thing well then where's my outline no we
aren't
okay that is bizarre we should
definitely have that now okay
let's make that right here so public
void add and teehee
so um entities dot was Wow we haven't
done anything here I was another thing
person that we actually had a bit of
gang going on here apparently not okay
there's gonna be a long F so sorry in
advance I'm not sorry you guys Center
like long episodes we really should have
a private list here called entities and
how the hell are we not how do we have
now we must have that here how we're
entering stuff
if we don't are you kidding me Wow okay
this is okay so what we need guys is we
need an ArrayList to store entities I'm
really sorry this is this is falling
apart because um I thought we had this
so now I don't really want to spend time
teaching what it actually does okay so
what this ARELIS does is it just can it
just is basically just an array of all
the entities that we should have in our
level the reason we're using an array
list and
standard all right it's because we want
it to be dynamic right so we only want
the size of this array to be as many
entities as we have in that okay and
again I'm just adding all these things
to our thing but anyway so we've got
entities now what we should be doing
right I don't know why we're not doing
that but over here in render we should
basically just be rendering all these
entities and in update especially
entities dot get I that's dot update
okay and obviously we need to put that
in a for loop all right cool
so that's going to update all of our
entities and we definitely should put
okay so this renders the level that's
cool
after we finish rendering the level
there let's render all the entities okay
cool um as if we don't know okay so
screen gets boss cross brilliant okay
well this is somewhat better now I don't
know why we didn't have it like that
before but over here in a dent is a we
should entities top okay okay
now we'll just add our entities
basically into the list that we need to
render and update and I hope that in
game we're actually updating our level
are we no not okay
so over here we should have a level
dot-com de suite okay so again I really
apologize for that I thought we have it
we had done that already
I'm sure you can forgive me because I
just realized three episodes in a row
and it's going to be for tomorrow oh no
sorry for episodes intro so yeah enjoy
you know you're welcome you know no need
to friggin like do anything for me you
know it's cool you know liking the video
could help though maybe make me a bit
happier anyway um so over here in play
on our mob alright we want to level that
add this projectile to the level now um
that's pretty good I think that's pretty
much all you do okay so that's some
really cool now what we need to do it
was a pretty
is have a random method so public boy
render um let's just because I can't be
because we've done so much in this um
I've got a lot of surprise here
let's just hope you looking to reuse a
sprite I guess um oh yeah well cross and
flower let's just this she's grass
okay so we'll set it probably the I
think if we use and just has to be
screen screen screen dot render what do
we have tile which is this so X Y and
the sprite will use a sprite and let's
start a sprite here so for this but was
it projectile will make this Friday pull
to sprite or price now we'll make a
sprite and everything next time um okay
okay
sweet so what I should do is that should
essentially round right column and just
check this at this correct um oh this is
correct yeah this is this should work
okay cool so again you know we'll see
what happens again nothing happened a
little one that happens okay let's come
back here um that's an MC that is
correct
um I oh man
hang on a minute
okay X okay okay okay so this should
probably be hang on to beat X do we ever
even set X correctly I think it is
working it as it gets in the wrong place
X origin equals x and y yeah but
we kind of need a set this at X equal to
X and this dou y equal to Y that's kind
of important all right there we go yeah
so it's not perfect in fact it's seems
to only be doing some angles and it's
probably because of I don't why that's
happening that's because our but yeah
you can see that it's working so that's
cool I guess probably because I'm I
think I think this can actually take
degrees I think that okay maybe not um
there is a way to make it take degrees
though I'm fairly sure
okay let's go back into uh where are we
this isn't was a projectile right yeah
go back to projectile make that is a toy
that is an angle this should be double
them oh my goodness cannot type bros
what's up okay let's go back into mob
and let's not curse at to an end mmm so
what happens oops oh okay there we go
okay yeah there we go so you can see
that that pretty much works here right
we've got a bunch of things here so
there's no collision all right that's
one thing that's kind of not not correct
we're also you can see that our angles
are not 100% accurate here you can see
that there are a lot of flaws here for
example when I actually removing these
things once they go once they go out
from range if we make the speed slower
so where's it projectile will make the
speed like 1 2 or something okay you can
see that if I just shoot this that is
really too fast I'm really slow on it
two players way too slow yeah okay there
we go oh there we go that's as fast as
like this thing this little blob here
will keep going forever so that's kind
of an issue we got to fix out obviously
but yeah I have a stopped
are okay right
anyway um there are a few issues here
that we need to fix up I could do that
now of course or we could not do now up
to you guys um what's our chapter you
guys to me okay um
right anyway okay so that's that's rough
shooting you guys can see how that kind
of works and that works pretty well
actually
ah but we need a basically implement
collision for these things we need also
implement you know a range and the
reason ranges that are because you know
fringe isn't there we're going to run
into issues like you know if I keep
doing this for a while like this game's
going to crash eventually you know you
can actually see the FPS going down so
at the moment the FPS is okay FK yeah
that's the FPS if I just need some for a
while we're going to start going down
pretty soon because it's not it's just
constantly adding them and that's kind
of an issue so right now we already blow
2000 FPS and if we sell the game clean
obviously we are at like 3000 so yeah
that's an issue and we'll fix out
everything so the issues we have to fix
now are basically angles range and um
let's go back into our task list okay so
to complete this we need to basically
fix angles so in other words make the
angles more precise we need to add a
range and then we need to add collisions
inclusion that's probably it okay so
that's basically what we've gone up to
so we have implemented it pretty well
right now
oh we need to add a sprite as well so
add a sprite and yeah let's that should
be it so anyway I hope you guys enjoyed
this some episode of game programming if
you did please hit the like button and
I'll see you guys some other time with
probably range that's what we'll do next
so I'll see you guys later bye
you